welcome to this video playing Elias
alias what is the right pronunciation ER
ok he's playing the London system not
one of the most exciting openings and
there's that there that there is around
that are round ok so let's see can I get
in quick d6 and e5 maybe I can this and
then going 45 is quite often a good idea
maybe like 95 and then if ifs as
possible that is interesting so um night
f4 will probably win the bishop pair but
damage my pawn structure quite a bit
maybe a rupee 8 just support the center
and I'm threatening fo I guess pushing
the pawn yep it seems I really
threatened that so what now maybe f 6m
f6b should be six or I wonder now yes
Bishop c4 where's he going after Bishop
f5 possibly edge to c5 I guess mmm I see
it's not so easy to play him there
should be six quite in a bishop see form
it's quite an annoying IDM maybe start
with that but Bishop c4 is quite quite
okay for him maybe bishop I'm sorry
maybe Knight b6 is okay then networking
might have a slight slight edge here yep
Jim might be and be a slight edge his
pieces are quite active
yeah still must be I think should be
right getting rid of this Bishop down
just such a strong Pisa on b3
you that's true actually rookie several
he might play but should be six and
trying to trap here but okay he cannot
take on b7 so shouldn't be the end of
the world there should be six rookie sex
night be seven on 27 traps that night so
not not that big of an issue and I'm
threatening luke t 7 which would
basically win outright if he allows it
hmm
cherrylle know this wide have some
technical solution like Bishop h for him
Bishop edge form but i guess i kinder
school g5 shouldn't be big issue yeah he
is playing it he is playing it
so he really is going for that stuff or
catching snakes if I go f6 what is the
big issue takes I don't get it f6 nite
nite f5 or maybe
so don't get it takes and what night f5
I mean I can also take the bishop on g5
I mean there's really a lot lots of
stuff hanging and I ok neither five I
can also just take v3 that is also
completely sufficient I guess
all night f5 ruki aid this is the
simplest Wow for Queen g4
uh yes so
cap that says it that's interesting as
weird as it is it is interesting can I
do this well yeah I guess I have to take
in check well that is that I didn't see
actually
that first and then Quincy form with a
sick game what a sick game shafted seems
he played it well at least I didn't see
anything remotely am as a refutation so
he has got what exactly look and three
pawns that's quite a bit that's quite a
bit of material my Knights don't don't
have any great outposts that's it's
really a problem okay maybe him check
time warning I need to go if I get to f4
still could be interesting a little bit
at least
yeah i mean i can i can still be quite
it can be quite annoying yes still for
something I thought 95 but it just hangs
okay maybe here check don't know what is
this sound just a ton of stuff down I
draw a lot of the draw you okay chazan
want to check wants to try to win check
yeah I offered the drawer with what
forfeits on time what can I do he
doesn't want it ja wow what a game what
a game so g5 so it seems that then f6
was was bad right what was the solution
then we should be three is right hmm
okay of course I cannot cheat with the
Queen at just d6 hangs ok added and this
is the much better way to do it like
here and then f6 and this probably is
not enough for the sacrifice peace now
but hear that that was very strong just
there's a very strong check check Joe
and Jim I'm just lost them
I'm just lost I really I saw that far
too late that he can check cheek yeah i
was thinking child check actually and
this isn't this isn't that great it's
nothing nothing clear hmm check check
check yeah I don't know what what
exactly was what's wrong here probably
nothing actually if I if I just take
here on b3 that that's really is the
point if I do that there's nothing
particularly bad happening to me ok well
thanks for watching